all right guys bang-bang
I've got ours in here thanks so much for
doing this man thanks for having me
appreciate it for sure let's just jump
right into to your background you were
one of one of the rare folks who's
actually built a successful business
exited wolf got a large corporation and
now spends time investing so kind of
just walks to your background yeah I so
actually grew up in the valley so my dad
had been in the startup ecosystem my mom
was there as well and I so I kind of
watched them literally start their
companies in the garage my dad's first
company that he'd started was a company
called Berkeley Networks there was just
a ton of folks that came from Boston
East Coast area this is a talking about
semiconductor networking see the real
people that built real companies at that
time they would they you know they would
literally be sleeping in the garage some
people were in their back here in their
tents I'm forgetting what kind of cars
someone had but it was essentially like
this big folks where I can like
campervan in front of our house and he
was sleeping there and he was just
coming in to take showers and so I kind
of watched that and to be frank I I saw
that and and thought to myself why would
anyone ever want to go through this much
pain to start a company and and and
again being a kid in your mind you think
of starting a company is like you know
starting a shop at a retail location
maybe at 7-eleven or something like that
and so never I never really liked grass
growing up what I really meant to start
a company or what was venture scalable
what was high-growth you know what was
revolutionary reverses what's disruption
oriented and so I actually and I think
we kind of share this actually had you
know enlisted for the Army in 99 and so
I went I went through basic got out and
you know they take they gave you a
series of tests to see essentially
testing your IQ level around what are
the types of things you can do and so I
never went into any sort of standard MOS
I actually went straight to a department
defense and there started contracting
with them before I was deployed out with
folks in the army between 99203 and
during that timeframe I I think what I
started learning was that there are so
many unwritten rules to the rules and
there's just so you can push the
boundary as much as possible but
learning what's available what's not so
I started taking classes I went to
community college at the same time
there's something about the time called
community college at the air force I
don't know if you remember that because
the army didn't provided and the
different military stipulations and so
then I eventually just transferred at
University of Maryland at College Park
taught a little bit of ROTC there as
well and then just you know studied math
and history never finished math I only
finished history and then the startup
ecosystem was actually starting to get
hotter and hotter in California where I
grew up so I came back and started a
bunch of companies and well while I
appreciate it you said hey I had a
successful company I had maybe 10 or 11
you know starts that didn't work they
all failed and they're not on my
LinkedIn I won't talk about them because
they're embarrassing but I tried
everything
nope photo photo sharing to
micropayments who you know payments and
wallets this is this is pre iPhone this
is during j2me & Brew and you're trying
to figure out how to use the phone so
timing was off obviously by you know 10
to 15 years but that was my background
and then eventually you know I started a
social gaming company out of my time
from Facebook on the on the Facebook
platform was a company called Lowell
apps we scaled very quickly I would say
we had a lot of tailwind and luck on our
side and you know we went to 0 to 100
million monthly active uniques 0 to 100
million revenue at some point but it was
never a straight line and what kept
going up and down because our
our game would scale and then it
wouldn't and then we get another game
and that wouldn't and so a lot of what
we tried to do is get enough games to
build distribution once we had
distribution we started distributing
other people's products we became our
own platform and not just here in the
United States on Facebook but we
eventually moved to mobile we started
publishing games from Asia here in the
United States and back into Asian
different markets and eventually we were
acquired by Nexon in 2011 so for about
quarter of a billion and that was
alongside a merger with company about
six waves so we all kind of came
together and we were their outfit to
publish games on mobile and so that was
you know that was a wild ride because
you we were taught how to scale an
organization so we went to a couple
hundred people fired a couple hundred
people went down to 30 scaled again to a
couple thousand people fired five
hundred six hundred people because the
games had oscillated and then we you had
to build infrastructure from from the
ground up so bottoms up how to think
about what it meant to build data
architecture what it meant to measure
your customers what it meant what a B
testing really meant during that
timeframe again AWS was just coming and
so we were using you know products like
SoftLayer which eventually got acquired
by IBM and and remember during this time
this is this is the first time where
storage started getting cheaper you
could retrieve it faster you could
analyze on top of it this is when data
and analytics company started merging at
a faster pace so that was a time when I
was growing up in my and my companies
were either succeeding or failing but
this is how you build your product and
engineering teams and so kind of fast
forward from there you know I started
another company called message me sold
that to Yahoo I was on the executive
team there scale their whole mobile unit
out to a couple billion in in revenue
from zero where they went from desktop
to mobile so and and we also acquire 250
companies there's kind of a wild ride
and the only thing that helped us
from our portfolio approach was using
some sort of data analysis or frameworks
to be able to leverage the data to make
decisions in the future and a lot of
people say they just use the word data
in analytics and then and I think all
their problems are solved but that's
that's not true it's more about what are
you measuring what are your frameworks
what's the philosophy around the data
that you're collecting and then how are
you gonna make decisions based off of
that and and I think you know the
companies that have done that really
well have been Google during their time
Facebook probably you know the most
prominent of them and we're more biased
er because that's our background it's
where a lot of our team comes from
Jonathan my co-founder a tribe you know
essentially invented the data science
practices at Facebook when you started
there so so a lot of you know you have
to kind of think about what does data
help you do and I started thinking about
what what can data help us to in the
private venture landscape you saw a lot
of companies and hedge funds and funds
in general you use you know third-party
datasets and publicly available datasets
to start thinking about how to invest in
the public markets and have some sort of
edge and and and you've all heard that
story you know there's a famous folks at
Renaissance they have their strategy but
you know the the list of folks that have
been successful but pretty long and we
you know we in the private markets
what's most important and what was most
important was the same work that we used
to do when we built a company from the
ground up from scratch which is you have
all this data storage is getting cheaper
retrieval of that is cheaper and you
should be able to analyze it so what are
the frameworks that you used to make
good decisions and so I eventually
joined a firm called social capital you
know there was three co-founders Tomas
who's more famously known because he was
at Facebook as well and it started you
know the growth initiatives and this
type of thinking within Facebook but he
had also helped start this ecosystem of
thinking in my opinion across the
Silicon Valley ecosystem and I had
joined because social capital was the
only firm that
was thinking about leveraging data from
companies their primary data to build
bottoms up view to make better decisions
and so what I really pushed forward
during that time was great we can do
that but how can we help to augment the
companies that we work with how can we
make better decisions ahead of time how
can we store and query this over time so
that we can get better at our decision
making but as venture capitalists out of
augment our time of you know of our
experience is really like I've been an
entrepreneur of scale companies who
cares there's a certain amount of time
that goes by that it's less relevant but
it only becomes relevant if I have data
in context to understand how companies
work and what's really happening versus
hey I saw this company ten years ago do
this or I saw another company six months
ago did this you should do it too those
are not really helpful and a lot of my
investors in my past used to do that
they would come into a board meeting and
they would basically just you know
reflect on other companies and what they
were doing and I remember one time there
was this one investor who said let's
take a look at LivingSocial and Groupon
and you guys are very good at
distribution we should do the same thing
and I was like we have a distribution
retention for our games we make money we
have well profitable unit economics and
we won we need to scale that and I think
a lot of people focus on short-term
metrics short-term vanity metrics in
some cases and so a lot of you know my
time and my colleagues time have been
spinning around what's the data that
matters the philosophy behind it and how
do you automate and build abstraction
layers on top of that to make better
decisions yeah so let's go back for a
second the the thing you said in terms
of you started much a company some work
some didn't but timing was a big piece
of this yeah I want to start it kind of
a 10,000 foot view of just I think a lot
of entrepreneurs especially earlier in
their careers don't understand that this
may be the most important factor right
it's just if the idea is time has come
type thing maybe talk a little bit about
through your experience both in starting
a company at the wrong time and then
also starting one you don't cut it at
the right time with the Facebook
platform stuff like that yeah
so if you if you use the word timing you
know it really goes back to in my
opinion for pedestals but people talk
about product market fit product market
fit is essentially just that it fits
within a certain time frame and then you
have a product that is working how do
you quantify that in a market that has
demand for that product how large is
that market at that time and then what's
the team behind it that substantiates
those two aspects and I'd say the other
pedestal in our opinion that people kind
of forget about is the distribution of
that product into that market
and and that's another piece there I
would say you know the the timing really
equals product market team and
distribution as a whole if you were if
you want to look at as a formulaic
perspective and the you know the the
products that I were I was building and
my colleagues were building you you can
say that either the timing was off at
the market wasn't ready for it or the
product you built just wasn't working
before the market that existed like it's
kind of either/or and I would say all of
my products had a failure of one of the
two at any given point when we were
first starting right where you know the
market was fairly saturated with the ton
of the same types of product so what you
were building wasn't any differentiate
it was a commodity so we call that kind
of red ocean markets right where you're
just building the same thing it doesn't
feel monopolistic it doesn't feel like
there's a unique value proposition
unless there's something really unique
and sometimes unique means distribution
but a lot of companies don't have that
either but when you're starting off from
scratch you know say zero to one you
don't have distribution you're trying to
figure out what's the wedge to get that
distribution and then in terms of how do
you evaluate that right so like I'm an
entrepreneur I want to actually build a
this company I've got this idea how do I
evaluate is this the right time for the
product yeah you know the what I'd say
is who [ __ ] knows right I think the
part of that is that there's a certain
amount of risk that your underwriting in
the beginning you know maybe it's a
vertically and
sass play into a certain type of market
that's never seen software are they
ready for not who knows maybe it's in
market that's not the United States it's
outside so it could be energy you know
real estate insurance it doesn't matter
I think there's just a certain amount of
risk capital that's needed and a certain
amount of risk attribution of founders
and teams that start with yeah I've got
this idea I think I have this problem
that I can solve let's just get it out
there and see how the market reacts and
so so I'd say there's a certain amount
of risk capital for that and the types
of people and partners that you want
there's no data at that time it's
basically like let's just say you and I
are starting a company the two of us or
and we maybe we get two to three people
to act on top of it what we're really
doing is we're just building some sort
of prototype we're building something
that has capital expenditures towards
some sort of our wine that ROI it might
be nothing is that hey we just learned
that this doesn't work or we just
learned that the market doesn't exactly
want our product this way we're seeing
all these demand signals to go a
different direction let's fill in that
direction and that's typically what you
see for a lot of companies it's really
rare
it does happen though that someone says
that I have this unique insight I'm
gonna build this product and then I'm
gonna be able to sell it what typically
happens is they'll make that pitch and
then they come out with the product and
then they start tweaking it for their
customer tweaking and tweaking and
tweaking until they've hone in on it
sometimes those companies start off as
services which is what we all know some
what SAS has really turned into and
either that's top down mid market or
bottoms up
but you know the the main thing I would
think through is that you know there's
no real data in the beginning you got to
have some sort of keen insight and then
as time goes on and especially in
today's day and age you do have data
that you that are that you're collecting
on how your customers are interacting
with your product and and the beauty of
software products are is that there's a
leisure to it there's a breadcrumbs of
how people will use it and that's
actually where we come in is that we
have like this guide map of what it
looks like to be a healthy company for
your industry at your stage and life
cycle
and here's how you should measure
yourself against that or benchmark
yourself against that and if you can do
that then you know where you are
quadrant or gradients of healthy to
unhealthy it's kind of like you know
you're getting ready to run a marathon
can you run it yeah and I guess part of
this whole idea of market timing is one
what are you bringing the actual product
to market but also the growth tactics
where you talk about the distribution
obviously there was a point in time
where using Facebook for massive
distribution and growth made a lot of
sense maybe somewhat argued now it
doesn't how do you think about also the
timing of the growth tactics that you're
using you know you know what I find
interesting is if you I was actually
reading the book from Howard bucks
Marx on mastering the market cycles but
what it really reminded me of the cycles
of distribution at the same distribution
techniques always work is just when do
they work and now what time do you use
them all right like if you go back in
history you know there's people that
we're using you know the the first ads
for newspapers from the late 1800s and
there even the early 1900s to sell snake
oil right and like vitamins and and
medicines or liquors or whatever they
called it and those tactics are the same
things that people use today it's just
that do you have the ability to make it
work or not right we're now 5-hour
energy just grew very quickly because
they were on TBS at like late nights and
people were tired and so I think like if
you have a much more longer-term
perspective on what distribution channel
is working what don't you know email
still works SML still SMS still works
newspaper advertisements still work it
just depends of what your product is who
your audience segmentation is and and do
you have a unique value proposition that
won't work I've always kind of found it
interesting that people say hey we have
this new unique distribution that we're
gonna go after and then you can go back
to and say okay well over the last 50
years like these are the people that
have done it maybe we should just learn
about how to do it better does your
audience segmentation work there or not
and I've always seen people try to use
you know the Facebook tactic
that we had used me you know for
enterprise infrastructure or hey let's
use let's just buy some ads on Facebook
for a top-down sales model and and I've
always questioned that I said well why
would you do that
that's not where your audience lies it's
not where your segmentation lies it's
not where you're gonna have intent
what's the point and so you know while
we get these new channels it's just it's
you know more of the same it's just
about how do you use those channels and
then how are you efficient with it you
know one of the differences in the
private markets and venture capital
compared to the public markets the
public markets have a price associated
to the asset every day it trades there's
a lot of volatility and so emotion
becomes much easier to manipulate just
because they're seeing something go up
or down in value in venture capital you
don't necessarily have the day to day
price movements but there's definitely
emotion that gets involved in
decision-making you guys I think I've
done a good job of just being super
data-driven maybe talk a little bit
about how I tribe you guys are using
data how it you know affects the
decisions you make and how you guys are
using that once you make an investment
to support the companies yeah so I think
there's a couple of ways to answer that
question there you know one is people
use the word data-driven where I'm
really immerse that because it just
means that you're just gonna go like
you're not gonna be you're not gonna
think about what this data means in the
first place and so we like to use the
word data informed internally and so we
came out with this framework called the
eight ball where it was essentially how
do we quantify a product market fit for
any company that uses software or is
enabled by technology in some way and
you know the the reason we had that was
it's it's a kind of financial accounting
right if you if you look at a statement
of cash flow or a balance sheet
you know P&L etc these are standardized
frameworks that were invented in the
late 1800s to help guide you on what are
the transparent things that you want to
look at for a company before you dig in
deeper so if you if you looked at a
financial accounting statement there's a
very good chance that you won't be
interested based on the financial right
like there
you might say no like you're nodding
your head saying like yeah like that
company doesn't feel healthy to me so
I'm just gonna pass them and look onto
the next thing
however if you if you find something
that's interesting say like you know
this the way in which this company has
cash management or efficiency or you
know overall their overall cash flow in
nature maybe I should dig in deeper and
you start doing your work from there
then you start thinking about demand
signals what does the overall what does
it our customer base look like was the
recurring nature of it with them what
does the margin structure look like if
it's lower is there as a market big
enough is a volume large enough where
they can get to a certain scale you
start asking these bigger questions
about different industries but then
you're able to compare multiple
companies to each other by using this
and then digging deeper but you know
what in the private markets one of the
issues has always been how do you do
that what are the standardized
frameworks that you use ken can you
actually measure it and financial
statements don't work as well for
early-stage mostly because those are all
lagging indicators so if you're if
you're investing in a seed plus or
Series A or series that a lot of these
companies have really de minimis revenue
or revenue that's really not gonna paint
its picture yet and that's coming later
and so you're looking at forms of demand
or engagement which is what I call it so
you have standardized frameworks for
that and that's really where we spent
almost all of our time now you can take
that in sit give great you can actually
do more the more data you have you can
do more of that for even later stage
companies and we do that as well because
investors typically kind of what I'd say
regress demeanors they just go back to
the finances and say hey they said
they're gonna do this but I don't see it
reflected in the finances sure but you
could have said that for Facebook Airbnb
uber at some point because you know
Google at some points well like you
would never really understand how these
businesses work unless you could look at
what we call the software ledger and
that's understanding the demand signals
for how a company works so our framework
was called the eight ball we published
this you know about six years ago my
partner done this he had publishes
actually even while he was at Facebook
you know if you're coming into Facebook
today as a product manager you read this
if you are learning product market fit
quantitatively like what are the
frameworks that you use at Stanford they
reflect our work you go to sequoias
website they have a section for product
market fit it links back to our work
because we created a standardized
framework to understand product market
fit for a company at a certain lifecycle
and and that's what we do really well is
to just get those frameworks out for
ourselves and we have a ton of software
to help automate that we have a ton of
software that stores all this for every
company we've ever seen so we can get
better at better at not just evaluating
but giving this insights and feedback
back to the company like if you're a
founder and you're starting a company
the first question you ask everyone is
like what does it take to raise a series
seed what does it take to raise a Series
a what does it take to raise a series B
what are the milestones I need to
achieve and we basically say here the
[ __ ] milestones that you need to
achieve and it's and here's the
gradients of where you need to be in and
and here's what you suppose seeds really
look like and what people are gonna
gauge you on and this is what we tell
our entrepreneurs this is where we think
we can help but more importantly because
it's standardized this is where this is
a standardized framework you can use to
reflect back to the market as well and
so we use this as a foundation to
understand where a company is that as as
lifecycle and then what its gonna take
to scale like what you know is this
gonna take 20 million 50 million 80
million of sub subsidization of venture
capital or the source of capital get us
to certain sizes Gillett so what venture
capital is all about right which is a
velocity of growth is what people are
trying to invest in I think a lot of
people kind of forget that right is it
it's a sub linear path is it super
linear or is it just linear and all
companies have different different
stages and and at some point I'm sure
we'll talk about network effect because
we both also come from that same
background but that's just as important
right is that you can only really think
about network effect if you have a
foundation to understand where a company
is in its lifecycle and do they have
product market fit or not you know
frankly most products don't have product
market fit that's what you want to know
do you want to spend your time as a
founder on something that's not working
and in my opinion if I knew that earlier
on I would say I wouldn't want to have
done those 10 things I would want to
only focus on the two that started
working because it had product-market
fit and I think part of this what you're
highlighting in terms of Sequoia and
Facebook really covering this stuff is
the first part of this is it's a mindset
it's a philosophy right of looking at
building a business in a very scientific
way measuring this stuff and the part to
me that's always been shocking is once
you kind of see the lighter or you get
indoctrinated to this then you look at
user metrics you see a whole different
part of the business because it's not so
much hey how many users do you have
right now you start asking differentiate
questions like what's your week over
week growth your month over month growth
what's the retention look like because
more nuanced questions can tell you so
much more about the business and really
what you guys have done is you've built
software that can do this in a very
automated fast way and also compare it
back to other companies you see yeah I
mean what we tell any companies that we
work with and you know we always say
feel free to ask any of our companies
why they wanted to work with us is that
I mean you pretty much have the Facebook
the uber or the Airbnb data science team
as your capitalist and and and and and I
say that not in a in a joking way is but
that's our background that's what we've
been doing and as individuals without
software we can only take you so far and
that's what most of the Joe schmo's of
the valley and the investors are is that
they pick someone or a collection of
individuals that had some experiences
qualitatively and bring them into a firm
and say like this is your guy or this is
your girl and she's gonna help you get
to where you want to get to where you
want to get to well the problem with
that as you know is that we just talked
about cycles of things changing things
change so fast you know the things that
worked for my companies over the past
ten years are not going to necessarily
reflect or work in the future so what do
you do well we've got to start with some
sort of foundation you got to understand
your your data you got to understand the
ground truth of what's working at your
company to be able to make more informed
decisions so if you are a network effect
company
or if you're a marketplace company or
you're a widget company or a grouse your
company you're you know you're
redefining what it means to be a
delivery company here in the United
States today you know given the kovat
pandemic and environment what how should
you think about measuring yourself
versus you know what you know facebook
measure themselves again yeah like do
you ever I mean it doesn't make sense so
it's more about like you know what what
are the ground truth type metrics and
demand signals that matter and then the
unit economics behind it a lot of people
have their own frameworks for thinking
through it my biggest issue has always
been those are always lagging indicators
right like looking at someone's finances
are lagging indicators for early stage
not late stage and so how do you then
take this super data informed approach
where you do have access to that
software legend you talk about do you
say hey we're just gonna listen to the
data and the data is gonna tell us what
to invest in what not to or is there
still an element of like kind of art of
investing what a lot of people say it's
my gut it's my you know personal you
know position or opinion on this not
actual data yeah you know I I always go
back to look the what why do you partner
with mesh capitals in the first place
the ideal situation is that there they
are long-term patient capital with you
that knows that your business is gonna
have ups and downs
you're not having price discovery like
the private markets on a daily basis
right you're only having price discovery
you know sort of maybe like twice a year
if that that seems that a high frequency
already and what what you're what you're
really trying to do is understand micro
and macro and I think this is important
and and the data sets behind that and
right now we've been talking about
primary data and micro and and
understand what is it gonna take for use
of proceeds to get companies to the next
stage to to you know to get them to a
place where they can sell sustain in
some cases some people call that
profitability some people call that like
you know high growth which is what the
market was you know valuing up until end
of December 2019 yeah it's I think kind
of the the best way to think about it
like what what are the milestones that
you're investing for in the future and
who are the folks that you're gonna have
around the table to do that and so again
I go back to the context has always been
let's focus on people and then as you
mentioned gut driven investments or can
you get a foundation or a context a
certain type of company and you have
software that helps augment that we've
you know with their workflow helped me
be a better investor or helped me be a
better board member or an active
investor but at the end of the yeas
active investors around here that are
coming on the board you're spending time
with them they strategically you need
them to help you they have a brand and
some capacity they have a network as
well for helping to hire or you know
corporate M&A etc and so you're choosing
them and so the the people you choose
are just as important as them having
context into your business and so the
way I kind of explain this is look if
I'm around a dinner table and let's say
you know it's a it's a Corp Deb style
conversation you should expect your
investors to have almost the same
context into your business that you have
maybe I'm not gonna have all the nuances
I'm like what you a be tested last week
of course not
but I should be able to explain your
business from the bottoms up around why
it's so important if I can do that
around the dinner table or you know over
a zoom call like this because I have
context I have you know my data inform
methodologies to do that that will just
make us better investors regardless and
I think that's always the case that's
the case when you are a GM of a business
unit or a head of product for a company
it's the same thing had a product has no
idea what's happening at the latest a be
test you know three or four orders down
like if you trace it they don't know
they're they're hoping that their teams
are accountable to get stuff done and in
the same way I think about it is on our
side which is as active investors and
minority investors in many cases we
should be accountable to understand
what's happening in our company and then
therefore the second-order and
third-order that is that we can help
them strategically because we just know
what's going on if you ask any you know
VC out there how is your company doing
they'll say that person is
they have they know what they're doing I
love how they're attracting the customer
base like all these high-level fluffy
Duffy [ __ ] and and then what they'll say
is they're killing it even if they're
not and you have no idea what's
happening and it you know if I and if I
was a employee and I got introduced to a
VC that just gave me those I just why
would I work there it just means that my
investors have no idea what's going on
and I can only really underwrite the
team and and the CEO the capital around
the table won't matter and and our whole
goal is capital around the table should
matter because in the past it has
mattered and if you really look at the
venture capital industry and where
they've been the most helpful that's
been the case yeah speaking of that you
guys recently put together some work in
pulled a bunch of data and analyzed
around this idea of fast money and slow
money maybe talk a little bit about what
that means and then what that work
showed yeah so we did we did two things
one was you know what was the failure
rate of companies during some of these
down terms and then what what are the
behaviors of capitalists you know
regardless of big venture capital hedge
funds private equity or family offices
what is their behavior in these types of
downturns and so you know what I kind of
you know I always go back to you know
most people don't understand cycles in
my opinion they haven't they haven't
been around long enough to see multiple
cycles and they haven't seen the lessons
of past you know historical cycles and
and so you know our goal was you know in
in the last two pieces that we wrote for
you know for our founders and in their
audience even our LPS was to kind of
give a perspective again on like this is
short-term regardless of whatever we're
saying it feels like every day is a year
and it feels like every week is a decade
is that you know in six months the world
is going to be different and so what you
really want to know is what's going to
be ahead in the future after the cycle
right like
and are you are you are we in fear mode
or greed mode and and I would argue
right now we're in fear mode and so
what's happening is that that's been
augmenting and propelling the way in
which people behave and so our whole
goal was that in these analyses if you
read through them you know who are the
folks that have the most fear how do
they retreat and how do they treat you
and are those two types of partners you
want to have around the table in a time
of despair and fear or do you want to
have partners which we could define a
slow money that are gonna be there you
know through through the thick of it to
understand where you are and continue to
support you and that may not be capital
it's maybe like strategically we should
think about doing X Y & Z whereas the
other folks you know they have a trade
mentality or a flight to safety
mentality and sometimes that mentality
is not helpful towards company building
a multiple building and compounding yeah
and I guess part of that is you guys
looked at not only the frequency of
activity but also kind of pre during and
after these crisis periods you know
where people even just around breaks I
think one of the most telling things was
just there's a lot of transactional
firms that were super active you get
crisis and then they basically disappear
they're cited there anymore forget about
being not great partners they're just
disappear sure yeah I mean look every as
much as every cycle is similar every
cycle is also different and so if you go
back far enough right like you can go
back to the 80s you can go back to the
early 90s and obviously the late 90s in
the 2001 and then you have 2004 and 2005
people always forget there's these mini
cycles as well especially in the
technology industry we had 2015 and 2016
and on the south side with LinkedIn sort
of losing about 50 percent of their
market cap you have these things happen
all the time
and people can get fearful and as you
know press PR and media kind of calm
compound that and conflate things where
they might not be needed and and so so
it was more about Yahoo's
you know the venture tourists over over
the capital tourists in this industry
and and you guys obviously had you know
the same type of winter in
the crypto space and you know the
question is who comes back who does and
who stays around who kind of believes in
the long-term viability of a certain
type of new market and that's the same
thing for venture in my opinion is that
the folks that understand venture the
folks that understand cycles folks that
understand long term building are going
to be sticking around and they might not
be able to stick around the same way
they were before but they're still
around and a lot of what we wanted to do
was to make sure that we could give this
information to our portfolio first as
well as the community around how to
think about building your long-term
strategy over the course of the next
year and so you also recently wrote a
big piece on cara de any kind of this
idea of n of one companies maybe let's
just start with Carta and kind of walk
us through the history you guys have had
with that company in which really
driving a lot of the conviction there
and then we can get into what nf1 really
means yeah sure so to give you some
background you know a lot of our work as
operators you know from our time and the
Facebook ecosystem at Facebook was
essentially we spent all of our time
understanding and building out data and
infrastructure products features to
augment and build network based
companies like that that's our whole
history and when you have a network
that's very strong it doesn't matter
what industry it's in you know you can
you know you can call it you know a
network in the marketplace excetera it
doesn't matter when you find something
that's special and a network is being
built the question you ask is how big
does this get and and a lot of humans in
my opinion have a hard time one thinking
linearly but imagine when you're asked
them to think exponentially it's just
it's just so hard and we spent all of
our time looking at all types of demand
signals how to quantitatively measure
Network effect everyone says the word
network effect but no one really knows
what that means every deck that you see
for even venture investors or companies
that are coming in they'll say we we're
again we have this type
network effect this is why we're doing
and then you ask them to define okay
well what does that network effect
really mean they say oh we just do paid
advertising well it's not really a
network effect
it just means you pay to acquire a
customer or you know we go door-to-door
style sales or bottom sell for top down
and we have a network effect you know
people know us it's our brand well
that's also not a network effect that's
up it's called a brand a lower scale of
economy effect starting economies of
scale effect and so what you really want
to be able to measure is how your
customers interact with each other what
you really want to be able to measure is
does your network allow you it does as
your network is being built are your
customers reinforcing each other right
so for the example we use for you know
Facebook was that you know as more and
more people came into your network your
experience on the Facebook platform
improved
all right don't have just one friends
you have seven friends at 14 you have 20
and now those friends are sharing photos
and those photos regardless of how many
people are linking it and liking it or
commenting on it it's valuable to you
and that's a network and so we can
always define the Facebook as you know
the atomic unit around Facebook was
actually the photos now you could tag it
you could like it you could we share it
and eventually became a media type right
where you don't share just your photos
you do videos and articles etc but you
have all the interaction points that are
different and the experiences that
different customers have are different
it's not the same or like your
experience the same article is is is
different than my experience that same
article because it's just the way in
which we are approaching it and so you
have this platform of this product but
it's different for everyone that's
interacting on it and so now we had
never obviously seen anything like that
in our lives before in an ecosystem that
was created on top of it you know and
that story obviously has gone through
and we've seen companies of similar
nature have those types of network
effects you know Alibaba I'd argue being
one of them you know companies like
WeChat in Asia etc so you kind of have
these things pop up all over the world
and so when you start questioning and
say okay well I wonder what type of
businesses and products
have similar style network effects in
their industry and will it be disruptive
or Rev revolution as that space the
first one we ever saw as investors with
slack and so we kind of you know double
down triple down quadruple down into
that company we were the first investors
you know post pivot what they went from
a gaming gaming company to a messaging
company for enterprise and we saw very
similar characteristics of network
effect there we measured that
quantitatively pre-revenue and I think
this is really important around the
engagement that was happening in that
network and what that was gonna mean and
the time that the business that you can
go if you look at slacks you know
product market fit today versus what
they had when they started it's pretty
much the same I like you can basically
say like here's their foundation and
they've just been able to scale it up
using the same sort of techniques and
what you're really augmenting is the
friction they might have created when
when that product came out right if you
really look at what's that makes like
special is not just intercommunication
but external communication as well you
know companies communicating with other
companies akin to email and so that was
the pitch we made and that was actually
the first time we had taken these
frameworks from Facebook and from slack
I started using the word and of one and
this is why we were at social capital
like using these frameworks and starting
to use where is this company stand alone
by itself category defining doesn't have
monopolistic characteristics for for the
wedge that they started in and so this
really gave us what I'd say a training
ground to understand what it means to
have a network effect business and where
else could this be applied to I think we
got very lucky
we saw the exact same thing
quantitatively from the bottoms up for
Carta at that time called shares like
the pitch of a shares was and I'll give
Henry a lot of credit as the CEO there
and one of the cofounders was that he
said I want to build a network effect I
don't know what that's gonna look like
but in order for me to do it I need to
have this centralized view of the world
versus a decentralized view of what
everyone else is happening right he's
very contrarian
everyone else at that time was talking
about crypto blockchain distributed
systems I'll be able to interact like
you know programmable money and currency
and when he came away with that we need
to be able to systematize and you know
work within the bounds of what the
customer wants first and what that
really was was what we called the issuer
or the the assets or the stake holders
for a company and and that and that's
what they had built out and so it was
the first time we saw engagement and
network effects quantitatively for the
bottoms up of employees engaging in a
platform companies themselves engaging
in the platform you know similar to
payroll it benefits GPS at firms and
their back-office engaging with the
platform and then their investors
engaging with that platform you had you
had this really weird but extremely
engaging a set of nodes and edges
interacting with each other but there
were so far away from each other at the
same time like you don't have the head
of Harvard endowment deal with someone
at you know gusto that owns the share
but they're both stake holders of the
exact same asset and they're all in one
platform and so that was really exciting
to us and so you know a lot of what we
wanted to do was understand you know
they have one business which was a core
cap table business where you charge to
understand what it you know what it
means to manage your cap table and all
the stakeholders that come on board
there there's a lot of competitors in
that space at that time and I met
another business called the foreign a
nyan foreign a that you had to do in
order to define fair market value in
order to issue options for your
employees right this way is very
employing company and issuer specific
and over time what you were able to see
was that as the network got larger and
larger you know again akin to the the
photos parallel that I mentioned for
Facebook and then building multiple
businesses on top of it a card I started
saying because we had spent a lot of
time with them talking about the nm one
framework talking about what anatomic
value means talking about what they
means to have gasoline on top of your
atomic value and and and how to scale
you know they they came up with another
product for a
different set of customers that were
already in the platform that we're
engaging I think this is really
important is that you have so many
people engaging in the platform what are
the types of products and revenue line
items that you use to start monetizing
them and then they build what we call
fund administration which is essentially
you know all the back office work that
you need to do to understand your
portfolio all the rules and compliance
regulations that go with it for venture
funds private equity funds and hedge
funds and and and they launch that and
so what you had was this new revenue and
new engagement a new product and on the
same note and I think this was key which
is that it's all interacting with a
portfolio of assets that you own and
then what are the types of products that
you build for them and and what that's
really led to is what else can you do
there's banking and financial services
for these companies in some cases
lending yeah because you have a now a
distribution of you know 15,000
companies in the platform you know we
say a trillion in equity and we think
that's really important it's kind of
akin to tau of MA use of companies of
engagement on Facebook platform and then
you have a million stakeholders in the
platform and so the question you really
ask is what happens when you 5x that or
10 X n or 20 X that you know worldwide
this is just in the United States alone
how large of a company is that and is
and it's the first time in in our
opinion in financial history in the
private markets where you have a really
good transparent look through and and
and and you can start building a new
type of market like if if you really
think about it people have talked about
democratization of capital in in this
country in the United States where we're
a democracy democratization of capital
is only 3040 years old like where you
had you know securitized loans
collateral collateralization of bond
obligations of loans etc that that
industry is 40 years old and and look at
how many jobs were created because of
that look at how much access to capital
so much more people got because of that
new underwriting procedures that came
way because of that and so we kind of we
kind of think about card in the same way
which is like what happens when this
network is large and larger and and what
does democratization of capital look
like in the private markets where the
liquidity has been so constrained for so
long and actually this is where I get a
lot more excited is what happens now
when the crypto markets getting involved
on top of a platform that has
transparency what does it actually mean
versus a platform that didn't have
transparency before and I think that's
what we that's what I start getting
really excited about which not just on
Carta but you know other areas and
industries where you can do this
real estate you know go back to
mortgages and loans you can go back to
understanding what does it mean to have
access to capital and it's called
democratization of capital in those
industries and what does that look like
not just you in the United States but
worldwide as these things become more
and more interconnected which I think a
lot of people forget about yeah one of
the things that you mentioned is kind of
these early-stage businesses where you
can really start to see the network
effects and so if you put yourself in
the operator seat at Facebook I think it
was like can we get you ten friends in
seven days right or something like that
at slack I think I've read that it was
like twenty five hundred messages among
a team and then you knew that you had
them and they were gonna stay retained
what were some of the metrics that you
saw early on with a business like carpet
which maybe it's not as obvious to
people that it's a network effect
business but you guys by looking at the
data could really tell is it
number of stakeholders is it
transactions logins like how do you
actually think about that from the more
tactical standpoint yeah I mean if I
would really urge anyone to read our you
know Carta manifesto there there are a
lot of things that are trade secrets I
won't go into that and you know it's
competitive in some ways to companies
that want to compete with card on the
long term but but i but I think you hit
the nail in the coffin which is
essentially that the stakeholders on the
ecosystem and the equity value behind
those stakes is what matters the most
and and I always go back to it's a kind
of da you and ma you're right like your
form of engagement is that that not
every not every asset value or equity is
going to be equal and as time goes on
what does that really
mean and what are the types of products
that you can build on top of it now that
that's that's the main thing and again
when you're going back to a company
you're not talking about engagement
people logging in every day where you're
really talking about a number of
stakeholders that are in a company you
know in in theory you could say the
larger number of stakeholders and the
value of that stake that goes up over
time makes that stake more important to
the ecosystem up until a certain scale
and and and the question you have to
really ask is like what are you able to
do with that over time and and what does
that what did the companies in the
ecosystem look like what does that allow
the companies in the ecosystem to do not
just Carta itself like I know a lot of
people think about Carta but it's like
if you are a company on Carta what can
you do now you could stay private longer
just like Microsoft wanted to they
didn't want to go public Facebook didn't
want to go public
what are you allowed to do and how are
you able to think about long term growth
but at the same time giving people
access to be able to participate in that
alpha rather than singing it has to be
in the public markets in the long term
if you really look at it private markets
have just gotten larger and larger and
larger and they're growing at an
exponential rate and I think that's the
key it's something that worries me at
the same time but it's also a trend that
I don't believe is going away because of
the way in which companies need to be
built for long term viability of
investments rather than short-term yeah
one of the things that people usually
talk about is always how do I find
product market fit how do I build the
network effect and from the investor
seat people talk about do you have that
monopolistic you know tendency you guys
use the terminology end of one but what
can happen between when you first get
product market fit or network effect and
it actually doesn't work out like how
have you seen people either break the
network effect or actually make a
mistake as they scale and the reason why
I'm asking that is is it a situation
where kind of like betting on the right
market an average team can be successful
because the market forces can take care
of it or is this something where it's
not good enough just to get the initial
product market fit and network effect
you've got to really actually make sure
that you don't screw it up on the way to
scale yeah you know that's
it's a really good question I would say
that any example I give you will have a
counter to it and that you know I I
generally believe that if you are in an
excellent market your team can be
average or below average and it will
still work and and the reason I say that
is there's just so many companies where
you can see that and and hi well I won't
name names but I think they're quite
obvious when you start digging into who
they are I think it's extremely rare to
find a good team
in a good market building a good product
and and you know I will be bold enough
to say that I think you know Facebook
has been one of those unique companies
where they had all three and and you can
see that in the way in which they
execute and what they do they've just
been very very good at executing their
product across all these markets now you
think about all the other companies and
say okay well what do they do really
well or versus what they don't and most
of these companies I would just argue
they're just in very very good markets
and they were able to have product
market fit in those markets and they and
they're riding on the tail winds for as
long as possible our goal is to try to
find companies that were just like
Facebook that we're able to recognize
that a they had a good product I need to
build out their team and make sure they
can continue to execute and then they
can continue to ride market tailwind and
use those tailwind for the next adjacent
markets that they want to get into
versus hidden to headwinds like a lot of
companies do over time and so I don't I
don't have any hard and fast rules there
or what we advise you know our job as
investors is as I mentioned before is
think about micro and macro a micro side
is where we use our quantitative
frameworks to help evaluate and judge
companies but then share all that back
with the company right our companies get
like these 4050 page reports every
quarter and and they love it I remember
one team came to us and said yeah we
went on a knife off-site for three days
and all we did was go through line by
line your guys's whole analysis and to
me that that's great because that means
we are adding value to our companies
because we're just making them think
we're not telling them what to do we're
not telling them if they
are good or bad we're just giving them
raw ground truth any bottoms of you
around how to view themselves and it's
up to them to make decisions on how to
execute and we've been doing that across
you know multiple companies we do that
for a few public companies today and and
we've been helping you know some folks
even underwrite risk on the debt side
using these same frameworks because the
standardized and and it's helpful and I
can't and I can't echo that enough I
think it's really important just make
sure you have ground truths
before you start any decision-making
that's qualitative or quantitative and
then and then what I'd lastly add is
that in order to understand macro
environments you need to have a
perspective of microbe it's really hard
to make any sort of projections and I
think we're all typically as humans very
bad at making sure projections anyways
on what's happening in the macro
landscape right like I'm not an
economist you know I won't you know I
can't give you a very good honest
perspective on GDP and you know what's
happening in the ecosystem today but
what I can tell you is if you give me a
set of thousand companies where I have
primary data I'll be able to give you a
pretty good bottoms of view and
understanding how they're performing and
how healthy they are and the demand
signals that go into it
because those are our frameworks and
ideally that can help inform a macro
perspective right as mnsure investors
our job is to understand what's
happening today as clearly as possible
you know benchmarks says this very well
very well
as investors the reason they do well is
to understand the present clearly you
need to you need to understand that in
order to understand the future which is
what is actually happening it's really
easy to say we need to do these five
things or you need to build for the
future you know invest in you know
biotech you know sci-fi and and I think
we think of that as well but you got to
understand bottoms up where we are in
order to get there if you want to get to
the moon you know you got a cut a lot
rockets to get there if you want a 3d
print on the moon you got to get there
first as well and so understanding point
A to point B transportation supply chain
all of that is a part of what we do yeah
how does that change when the macro
environment changes so take like Kovac
for example there's a number of shifts
obviously one everyone's gotta go sit in
their house - you get things like in the
fundraising environment there's
definitely a bigger focus on
profitability versus maybe growth and
then three is I think a lot of people
look around and they say hey valuations
are gonna change they're likely to come
down how much how quickly that there's a
lot of questions and if you don't have
data you don't have those answers or you
guys able to use some of the data
frameworks and things that you've seen
in those past cycles in order to inform
it or you know like how do you actually
apply this in these kind of weird
transition periods yeah absolutely
you know it's what's interesting is that
when you get raw ground truth data you
were able to go back and reflect on
things that might have happened in the
past and you know I know it sounds like
a history lesson but like you go back to
the 1600s and you go back to the 1700s
1800 1600s you know the the currency of
barter or if you want to call it the
reserve currency in some cases was
tobacco you know and after tobacco was
cotton and during that same time line it
was cotton and sugar before we started
moving into gold and silver because we
had production I said if you go back far
enough and you say okay well what was
happening to these markets at that time
companies that were being created
incentive alignment that was happening
you know you know 400 year history of
I'm gonna call it colonial and US
capitalism what was happening and and
and had these types of things happen
before the answer is yes you know we've
gone to war we've shut down demand
access to other countries and and
companies as you know States were being
formed in the United States Civil War
something very similar it happened so
you really talk about it you say okay
well what are the types of decisions you
make as investors what are the types of
decisions you make as entrepreneurs what
are the types of decisions you make on a
macro side for the smaller medium
businesses that are essentially what 99%
of the employee base in the United
States I think roughly like 1.5 trillion
and payroll like all of these things
have second third and fourth order
effects and so when we think about
coconut
one it's a force government shutdown I'm
not saying that's negative it's just
that's what it is
and we're and we're fighting this war
against pandemic that is indiscriminate
in some cases like you and myself any
person of any purchasing power it's
affected and so what what does that mean
for the markets when demand can
systematically get shut down and has to
get shut down and then how long does it
take to recover so as investors you can
I don't have to understand okay where
are we in that cycle what is the effect
post cycle and is that still a down
cycle of fear and then what happens
after that and then what are the
companies that are able to sustain and
exist within that time frame which are
the ones that need help or subsidization
not necessarily from us and then where
do you start placing your bets from in
terms of growth where do you start
placing your bets in terms of what needs
to be built that doesn't necessarily
have to be software you know software
infrastructure technology energy
insurance etc the list kind of goes on
and and we're gonna be ecosystems that
are going to either be rebuilt or
augmented because of what's happening
today right and so a lot of people look
at the short-term what do they say they
say oh great no shipments are going up
for essential items and groceries are
going up oh well humans also kind of
regress the mean six months from now or
we're gonna do the exact same thing and
I'm pretty sure we're not going to do
the exact same thing but we're gonna be
really really close and so you go back
to past cycles in China when we had you
know the first SARS situation that
country retrofitted itself to be able to
withstand these types of things in the
future and they're doing a pretty good
job to get out of it you know I wouldn't
say perfect and so they were able to get
to get to some sort of recovery faster
I'm not saying yeah there isn't a
downturn but some sort of recovery and
so what does that mean here in the
United States and where do we start
investing our dollars and our capital
and our time and everyone has a
different perspective and and I think
the cracks that you see today are
housing healthcare and education we've
been talking about over ten years but
you've never really seen the cracks till
now now you see the cracks right like
on the healthcare side I mean this is a
you know from a overall inflation rate
since like 1995 I think it's like 55
percent that basically means things have
been getting more expensive it's been
getting harder and it's an out of reach
for people that were what I'd say you
know a plumber that was making you know
thirty to fifty thousand dollars a year
today was making the same amount you
know 20 30 40 50 years ago I mean they
just make less money than they did today
because of that and that's important so
the unskilled labor work first versus
the skilled labor workforce and the
change of that as well so I'm going to a
lot of concepts talking about a lot of
stuff but I think those are the things
that are important because those are
what drive our demand and our economy
and then you have underlying companies
that need to support that may that be
small the medium venture-backed or large
corporations yeah would it be fair to
say when you're evaluating individual
companies you're very bottoms up but
just hearing you talk through a lot of
this in past conversations we've had I
think that you guys take this macro view
of kind of where where are we today
macro wise where are we going and then
you go look at the companies in those
areas in which you guys believe will
have upside in the future and a lot of
times it's even places where maybe
they're not popular today but they end
up being and then when you find those
companies you start bottoms up is that a
fair way to view kind of the process you
guys go through about say on a
week-to-week basis even on a month to
month or a year to year we might have
theses that continue to get form top
down by our bottoms up work and vice
versa right where our assumptions I
think the way we think about is the the
the when we get into the room and we're
assessing any company anything bottoms
up is that we just don't know anything
we just check everything out the door
and so we just don't know so what are
the assumptions we may have made they're
wrong what are these new assumptions we
should start making now based on this
data and how does that help inform us
for our long-term capital to point
remember we're venture investors so our
timeline is 5 10 15 20 years in some
cases as an angel investor I have a I
have an investment from 2005 that's
still not liquid right it's still there
and I'm still hanging on
and and then we start thinking about
going from 10 to 50 to 100 and 200
investments that your your thesis has to
be different you have to start thinking
about your portfolio your liquidity
means for yourself in your LPS but also
what you need to do in order to make
better decisions in them macro and micro
environment the reason macro is
important is you have to understand the
bottoms of demand signals you see are
they going to continue to see tail winds
are they gonna hit headwinds are they in
a regulatory environment or not and and
I think you know what you've seen
unfortunately in again housing education
in health care sort of being the main
ones that focus on the reason why
they've had a harder time is that
they're they're more akin to political
and regulatory behavior where you have
institutions that are set to make sure
those things stay status quo it's hard
to invade and so even if you see a
company that's bottoms up they might
have a small initiatives working then
gets locked down by the regulatory side
of the house and and sometimes that may
or may not work right like in the case
of uber they had a lot of turmoil sort
of left they were able to make it
through because what was happening is
that we were moving away from a world of
being regulated to a world of being
unregulated to make it more beneficial
to the consumer make it more beneficial
in my opinion to the folks that were
being employed to make money through
that remnant inventory same with air B&B
et cetera so you kind of have to look at
that and say well what is what are going
to be those types of change that will
happen that are effective for education
healthcare and housing and the question
you ask is in this environment is that
helping to accelerate some of those
industries to deregulate and get more
innovation and to be able to help build
in that direction or are they going to
stay status quo and that's where we
spend a lot of our time thinking through
which is you have to understand that
part of the macro and and gather data on
that side as well and that's hard part
like that's the art on top of the
science which is science is not going to
tell us what's going to happen we're we
can only know what's happening on the
ground and we can only know
again bottoms up you know you know
actual trends and demand signals we
don't know how long that's gonna last
depending on what type of environment
what type of investment we're ranking
and so that's why we do focus a little
bit of our time on lobbying we focus a
little bit of our time building those
relationships with you know central
government and no I think a lot of
people don't like to say it but you know
I think the biggest threat to the United
States is not understanding what's
happening in Europe what's happening in
Africa what's happening in India and
what's happening in China and China more
specifically now I'm not I'm not like I
think longer term we have a better model
of incentive alignment here in the
United States like we have last 400
years however China understands their
incentive model they're copying us
they're getting into that direction and
even though they are centralized they've
been figuring out ways to deregulate
pieces of their economy to be able to
innovate the same way which we do here
in the United States but at the same
time they do have a top-down macro
perspective on what they need to focus
on and we've lost a lot of that in my
opinion here in the United States
post-world War two
up until maybe to the early to late 70s
and 80s you know I went to a China what
they call the de china FinTech
conference and who here's who put it up
you had the state government of China
the People's Bank I'm forgetting the
name of China
you had the top 10 universities stand
this up and there was only one outside
speaker and one outside participant and
that was me and I went there with
thinking I'm curious to see what was
gonna happen and I and I and I did a
keynote speech there on behalf of not
just us to even our company card on
what's happening in the financial
industry and on there you know before I
had started they had a couple days of
all the companies that were pitching you
had some of the you're the heads of
government you know the heads of states
there you're the heads of universities
there yet innovation cycles you have
startup companies they're like the top
10 and then you have folks like $0.10
all about all these guys they're talking
about what's gonna happen you basically
add the smartest people in the room
regardless of market cap talk
about what is important and guess what
they were talking about they were
talking about how much we need to pay
attention to crypto what reserve
currencies look like in the future where
they need to innovate where they need to
subsidize where the government is to
spend more time helping companies get
off the ground and where in the world
should they be paying attention and you
know luckily for us you know I you know
we've been in the lead for a while but
we have to be kind of vigilant is that
they basically said the only country we
need to pay attention to the only
innovation centers we need to pay
attention to nowhere else in the world
we need to pay attention to is the
United States and Silicon Valley
specifically it's incredible to hear
that literally we sit around and we
don't understand many of these regions
but they're just solely focused on us
you just mentioned crypto Bitcoin a
couple of times kind of how do you guys
think about that entire sector of the
world and you know what's possible there
have you done any investing on that
thing yeah we so while we're at social
capital we invested in a company called
second market and second market had sold
a portion of their company I'm
forgetting who they sold it to as Nasdaq
as tech secondary markets that's what it
became and then they became a holding
company a market maker and investor all
at the same time yeah so most of our
exposure through crypto had been through
them and this is a Barry's company and
you know they they were essentially our
our overall holdings and exposure into
the crypto markets from blockchain
crypto and you know over time what that
really did was when we got exposure to
all these companies like coinbase some
that you guys are in co investors with
you guys as well as us starting to think
about where do we want to spend our time
what are the types of that's that we
want to make and and to be frank we
didn't make a lot after that you know I
think a lot of it was for us to
understand where are we in that cycle
are we still in the winter or are we
still in a fear-based cycle of what
crypt is going to look like you know
coin and all the alternative currencies
and then what does it mean for the space
I think I still have a perspective that
it's still very speculative there is
some volatility there so it's hard to
think about how you innovate on top of
it I think the main thing that's really
interesting at the end of the day and a
lot of people have talked about this
much smarter than I am
I am about it being programmable
programmable capital program a little
money and so when we talk about
democratization of capital what does
that mean could this be a facility to
help augment and I think the answer is
yes absolutely
and and I think there has been more
innovation on what crypto and this
protocol of you know through blockchain
and and these methods that you can use
outside of the United States and here in
the United States and I think that's
where we are weak where we're not even
willing to understand it we're just so
scared of it from like a political
nature and that's what we kind of fight
the push is uh you know how do how do we
understand it more before we start
thinking about investing in it and I
think you're going to have Bottoms Up
investing you have to have top-down
investing top-down subsidies in some
cases or a research again I always go
back to World War two you know the you
know during the time of Bush and the
entity he created in alignment with our
military to be able to just you know do
basic research that could help propel
industry on top of it and I think we've
lost that you know and I think a lot of
what I'd like to see over time not just
from the venture community but
accelerators grant institutions as the
government in some cases to move back
into great maybe crypto isn't where we
want it to be today but what could it be
and what can we start incentivizing
people to work on that's not just pure
bottoms up or speculative in nature and
and I think what you've seen most so far
has been speculative in nature some
companies getting to a certain level of
success but them stagnate very quickly
and and where we want to spend our time
is not just you know financial markets
but just you know where does that help
across the ecosystem and go back to our
roots of what we do really well is
understanding product market fit
quantitatively
understanding how that can scale and
where we deploy our capital towards a
business being built around being
augmented you know leveraging and
utilizing distributed system crypto in
some cases blockchain etc because the
technology that's protocol that you can
augment rather than it being the
solution yeah think about like the
market size being either empowering or
limiting it what I mean by that is
crypto is big if you talk to some people
but on the grand scale of things it's
very very small compared to most
technology markets you're kind of
addressable user bases does that you shy
away from that is it more or something
hey we understand where it is today we
kind of see if it could seems to grow
you know five six seven years from now
it could be the size that we need or
just like what's the thoughts there on
market sizing yeah you know the
everything starts small right III I
think people as I mentioned before
people have a very hard time
understanding exponential growth like I
like how do you comprehend it it's hard
and so when you think about crypto what
what has already happened in the last
ten years it's amazing right how much
it's compounded forget market cap just a
amount of people engaged the amount of
open-source folks focused on it
applications that are people are trying
to put together from payments to wallets
to money transfer even if it doesn't
work who cares the people are trying and
then once you get to a standardized
framework that people start all agreeing
to that helps propel the next stage is
the next stage the next stage so I mean
even with the internet look how long it
took to get up and running and so so
what I'd say here is that you you you've
you have people on the bottoms up doing
things and you have a certain amount of
risk capital there I think the ico
market really [ __ ] stuff up I think
there were a lot of people similar to
what I'd say 99 in 2001 people just
heard the word technology or dot-com
just wanted to get involved that's a it
was like that it's the panic buying on
the upward trend but we're all gonna
lose out and so like the moment my mom
was saying hey should we look at crypto
or my brother-in-law who knows nothing
about
the space saying shy invest in Bitcoin
you know things are [ __ ] and so and I
think and and we hit that during that
you know a couple a couple years ago and
so now the questions are being allocated
not now we have a foundation where do we
build from here
and so I really pay attention to is like
what happens to the next two to five
years and five ten years with you know
what bitcoin is the currency
I don't know if it ever becomes a
reserve currency you know a lot of
people talk about it but I go back I
always go back to history what was
reserved for awhile you know you can say
US was a reserve at some point no post
world started post-civil war up until
World War one you know with the the
advent and the droppage of the gold
standard but there's always something
that people kind of hold on to and and
will Bitcoin get pegged with other fiat
currencies I don't know
and what do you build on top of that
versus top but I again I always go back
to number one we had securitisation of
mortgages mortgage-backed securities
truth has debt collateralized bonds
obligations loan obligations that is
only 30 to 40 years old I think
everyone forgets how large that industry
is in the trillions and and and how much
billions of dollars get traded on that
every single day and what that looked
like when it started pretty nascent so
here we are in the crypto markets it may
not ever yield anything but it has a lot
of legs where we've already started and
so you think forward 10 years 15 years
what happens what are you build on top
of it and you've already seen it I think
you guys are already investors in you
know in terms of lending in terms again
it securitizing it it seems small and it
is Mason but again bottoms up
what happens over time and what are the
leading indicators and demand signals
that you should really care about in
order to either participate invest or
innovate on top of yeah it makes a ton
of sense to questions before you I let
you ask me one question and this thing
you're the favorite book that you have
or most important book you've ever read
yeah
so there's always the new one I'm
reading I actually always go back to
reading the same book
over and over again and the books that I
like reading are mastering the market
cycle I like reading exaggeration
exuberance there's a book that my
colleague Jonathan recommended to me
called the righteous vine just about how
we think and what gets us there a social
contract perspective and social
psychology and I kind of put all of
these things together and I reread them
because that my experiences change every
three six twelve months every two years
they changed and I go back and I reread
them and I don't know what I when I
glean from it is just new learnings and
so I'm a I'm a larger fan of rereading
the exact same books over and over again
versus opening up and and I kind of the
way the reason I think about that is
that you know as an entrepreneur as an
investor you know you read a lot of
books about how to become an expert in
something it doesn't happen overnight it
takes five seven people call it seven
year cycles and so a lot of what I try
to do is how do I take a lot of these
lessons that other people have had on
top of what I'm doing today and how can
I become more and more of an expert of
what we can do really well not just me
as an individual but as a firm and as a
team and so and so those are the books
that I like to read over and over again
and I think one book that I keep going
back to as well is a zero to one by
Peter Thiel like I think I'm much more
in line with his types of philosophy
he's not not not 100 percent of them but
a probably like a 70 to 80 percent
overlap and then and then all of these
other concepts and books and those are
probably my favorite books books that
are all around frameworks on how to
think you just ride on off some pretty
good ones there so not a bad answer
you you've got an eye for space and made
a number of investments and kind of
spent a lot of time there believe in
aliens think they're real so so let me
tackle why I care about space or climate
change health care education the reason
I care about one is that I I am a
die-hard American I know it's kind of
like a negative thing to say these days
but I'm here but privileged to be born
here
you know we my dad was successful
because of the
opportunities that lie here and so a lot
of what I think about is what are the
type of next growth factors that are
gonna come the United States what's hard
what's hard to build and what are the
types of companies that we need to
invest in and make that happen so while
we have this core business of how we
think about quantifying and recognizing
an amplifying product market fit the way
I think about it also is just being
responsible is we there is a certain
amount of capital that we want to put
because our overall historic loss ratios
are low that we want to put towards the
high-risk endeavors but what should
those high rest endeavors be so I think
about American exceptionalism and
American ingenuity and where can that be
I think about 3d printing manufacturing
parts of education parts of healthcare
and and I think in order to do that you
need to have a certain amount of social
capital human capital and access to
capital and we're privileged to be in
that situation so we invested in space
and a company called relativity space
and that was all about 3d printing
rockets
from the ground up which sounds like a
crazy idea when we invested in it where
we could again where you could build and
3d print a rocket as quickly as possible
and the frameworks we use there was that
what could happen where you could design
iterate and launch a rocket in sort of
the same types of ways in which you
think about software like if a rocket
doesn't work
how can you redesign it iterate it and
3d print in and shoot it back up to see
if it works and so that's what this
company has been doing you know when an
engine didn't work they would redesign
reiterate it's something that would take
people one or two years they could do it
in seven days or 30 days so you take
that concept down say well what happens
where you can do that not from just the
engine but the full rocket full rocket
to a multitude of rockets to a multitude
of payloads and how do you get from
point A to point B so their whole goal
is like they want to get to the moon
they want a 3d print on the moon and
that's what we invested in was a company
called relativity space and again it's
all about American ingenuity
American jobs focused on building hard
things and so they're based out of LA
Seattle and Louisiana and
and then other company was company
called sail drone was the same concept
which is you know just as much as space
the world's oceans are just as hard to
innovate on top of envelope
what do you build and there's this
company called sail drone that started
you know as a science project but they
were able to finally go from technology
to platform to problem-solving and they
do the same thing you know instead of
NASA the world's oceans Institute that
similar is called NOAA and the company
works you know very closely with them as
well as being here in the United States
and working with world governments but
even US government to help understand
measure quantitatively our world's
oceans our weather and what's happening
on a minute-by-minute basis not on a
month-by-month or not by a cyclical six
six month time frame you you want to
know what's happening in the Arctic and
the Antarctic now you want to know
what's happening the buoy system that's
in the Pacific Ocean you want to know
what that because that is what informs
us and what's happening for our world's
oceans our weather our fisheries oil
exploration if you want to call that
from an energy perspective defense of
the United States if you want to go that
far as well all the way into how that
affects our agricultural components here
on land like all that stuff is important
and so there's no hard things and you
have to invest those and so we don't
take as many bets in those areas but we
take a small amount of its that we think
are again bottoms up where we have a
macro perspective and we want to take
moonshot bets if you want to even call
it loon shots we'll do that but we're
investing behind people that know how to
do this and we're spending a lot of time
asymmetrically with these teams or we
can help them stop function and that's
how I kind of think about it and then to
answer your question about aliens do I
think they exist that's a hard one all
right I think in the infinite realm of
possibilities of what the universe looks
like my my scientific side of me says
yes I have ticks we just don't know what
they're gonna be
are they humanoids or not or are they
some sort of you know you know bacteria
or single-cell organism that exists
outside here and I think you know we
have
theories about them already existing you
know on other planets maybe they'd be
dead or alive but I do think aliens
exist and the question that's up being
are they more akin to how we are and you
know like in in my in my lifetime I'm
not sure I want to meet anyone that's an
alien or anything because I would scared
the [ __ ] out of me because I would ruin
the frameworks about how I think about
this world and how we think about the
macro but a hallelujah you know I do
believe aliens exist and and you know I
think of nature but you know the you
know that that's how I think about it my
whole thing is just if if they exist
let's make sure we discover them they
don't discover us right it never really
works out when when you're the invaded
it's much better to be kind of the
invader if it has to come to that yeah I
mean there's this book I don't know if
you have read the expanse series at all
and then it became an Amazon sci-fi show
then an Amazon show you know there it's
kind of interesting to see how people
think about science fiction and what it
really means well my sense is and as I
mentioned humans are bad our projections
my sense is that you know we're focused
on becoming an inner planetary species
first and I think that's gonna we're
gonna be focused on for the next 200 300
years that's just that's that's what I'd
like to see happen and it's where I'm
putting our capital personal and our
venture firm over time and you've seen
some of our first bets there but we look
at that kind of across the board is that
if you think about the word growth and
what that means where we have to go over
time with eventually a stagnating
population will get there even though
there's the same like that we'll get
there and and new growth opportunities
space is one of those areas that we need
to focus on because the amount of things
that we can do in space versus what we
can do here the physics of being on line
here and on earth is very different and
there's a lot more innovation that
happens in space than I can and so you
want to make sure that you can reduce
the friction make it cheaper and build
there across the same types of
ecosystems that we invest in today you
know biology metals production
communication etc that's gonna happen
from space absolutely
you get asking one question to finish
this thing up what you got for me yeah
so why did you decide to invest versus
operator same question back to you that
you love asking us I think that what I
really began to realize is I enjoyed
building businesses but my favorite part
about building the business is going
from hey this would be a cool idea let's
test it let's see if it works
let's get some product market fit and
then when you get into the true like
scaling part of it to me the day to day
pieces of that we're less exciting and
so for me it was how do I go as early as
possible fine Conor to kind of continue
to just do that same exercise over and
over again in different markets and when
I first started investing full time I
don't know if I really have like some
master plan right it was more of just
like I know this one thing I really
enjoy doing I know a lot of other people
that are trying to do it but they've
never gone through that process before
and so as I kind of did that more and
more and more what I then started to
understand is hey I like these markets I
don't like these Marcus here's the types
of teams I like to work with all those
things and it's one of these pieces
where you guys obviously had a lot of
software and data analytics that helped
inform this stuff but like you
specifically have probably done you know
that initial exercise I don't know
hundred times now right and it's just
like you've got the pattern recognition
you know certain things that are not so
much shortcuts but just you can avoid
the potholes you can go ahead and you
know the test to run like all of those
things can really accelerate a team
together long answers as much as you get
to see patterns we like any other humans
we regress to the mean I [ __ ] up all the
time that's why that's why we have this
software and help us make make sure we
don't make those mistakes because our we
our gut reactions Thinking Fast and Slow
or not you know or sometimes not in line
with what's happening so yeah I mean
I've been watching you for a while and I
think you know we've obviously had
invested and won every company's way
back in the day and spent
kind of watching your progression so I
think you know I think it's really great
to see where you've gotten to things
that you care about now more than ever
and I'm watching that progression and I
think what you do now and how you kind
of informed well it's really important
and I think we all appreciate it so
thanks well I appreciate you coming on
here and we'll definitely do it again
awesome thanks for the time